this is john mcafee the eccentric tech
millionaire playboy suspected murderer
international fugitive presidential
candidate crypto enthusiast
and the same man behind that annoying
software called mcafee antivirus that
you probably have installed on your
computer right now if you have windows
and got the urban dictionary definition
for mcafee
mcafee a barely passable virus scanning
program that updates at the worst
possible times tends to render your
computer completely useless whenever it
starts an update
which it doesn't ask to start and you
cannot cancel
or pause leading up to his apparent
taking of his own life
john left a wild existence to put it
nicely they're really quite different
hello there and i do what i want
when i want the traveler's guide to
cheap
[Music]
when mcafee was 15 his father took his
own life and when asked about it by abc
2020 in may 2017
just four years before his own apparent
taking of his own life
this is what he had to say about it he
died when you were 15
15. he shot himself he shot himself yeah
people always look to the past to
explain the present it doesn't work that
way
june 9 2019 while saying he was trapped
in cuba
mcafee tweets this warning i've
collected files on corruption and
governments
for the first time i'm naming names and
specifics i'll begin with a corrupt cia
agent
and two bahamian officials coming today
if i'm arrested or disappear
31 terabytes of incriminating data will
be released to the press
july 23 2019 mcafee was arrested at a
port in the dominican republic
october 3 2020 mcafee was arrested at an
airport in spain while trying to flee
the country to turkey the u.s wanted to
extradite him on tax evasion charges
his manager takes the mcafee's twitter
account to post another warning if
jon misses his next check-in events will
be set into motion that i cannot prevent
once they have begun
jon has secreted data with individuals
across the world i know neither their
identities or locations
they will release their payloads if jon
goes missing
november 30 2019 mcafee gets the word
whacked
tattooed on his arm with the following
tweets getting subtle messages from us
officials saying in effect
we're coming for you mcafee we're going
to kill yourself i got a tattoo today
just in case
if i don't i didn't i was whacked check
my right arm
ticker symbol whacked also happens to be
a meme coin he made available only on
mcafeedex.com a website that is no
longer up
having dealt with governments i think
all governments are the same they
they they do not have much of a heart
sir june 15
2021 after eight months in a spanish
prison this video was released
it is certain that i will spend the rest
of my life
in prison because the united states
wants to use me as
an example
june 20 2021 five days later john's wife
releases this message on twitter
john's honesty has often gotten him in
trouble with corrupt governments and
corrupt government officials
because of his outspoken nature and his
refusal to be extorted intimidated or
silenced
now the u.s authorities are determined
to have jon die in prison to make an
example out of him
for speaking out against the corruption
within their government agencies
and just three days after his wife's
prophetic tweet
john mcafee found dead today in a prison
cell in spain
john mcafee has reportedly been found
dead in his spanish
jail cell john mcafee the legendary
eccentric tech entrepreneur
was found dead in his prison cell
outside barcelona and what authorities
are calling an apparent suicide
and within minutes of this news breaking
his official instagram account posted
this cryptic picture with no caption
referencing the online group that starts
with a q a ends with a none
that youtube doesn't like people
mentioning
and the 31 terabytes of incriminating
data that jon and his manager promised
would be released
it's nowhere to be found at least not
yet and also with the minutes of this
news breaking
you guys start blasting me on instagram
to make a video about it at jaketrain.io
if you're not already following me
so here we are did he off himself could
he as a 75 year old man with
deteriorating health not take it anymore
or did the us government have something
to do with it or maybe it was some other
corrupt government officials around the
world he managed to piss off
this is the ridiculous bizarre strange
rise and suspicious death
of john mcafee
[Music]
and this video was sponsored by mcafee
antivirus i mean magic spoon
you guys know magic spoon the insanely
healthy cereal that maintains that
healthiness
while tasting as good as all the sugary
unhealthy delicious cereal you had as a
kid
and you guys have been loving magic
spoon and as a tradition on the jake
tran channel you guys get to watch me
make a fool of myself while eating
cereal on camera
it's got zero grams of sugar 14 grams of
protein and only four net carbs in every
serving my favorite flavors are coca
chocolate fruity loose of fruit and
cinnamon and of course what other brand
out there would be okay with getting
plugged in a video
like this not many
support them and support yourself by
going to magicspoon.com jake trying to
get a variety pack right now be sure to
use promo code jig trend to get five
dollars off your order now in the us and
canada and magic spoon is so confident
in the product that is backed by 100
happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund you your money no
questions asked that's magicspoon.com
jake tran with the link below pause the
video do it right now alright you just
did it
back to the video john david mcafee was
born on a us army base in england in
1945
his mom was british and his dad an
american was stationed there with the
army
mcafee ended up growing up in roanoke
virginia his father was an abusive
alcoholic who would beat him
until his dad took his own life with a
shotgun in the bathroom mcafee was only
15 years old at the time in school
mcafee was definitely not the nerd you
imagine would become one of the biggest
tech entrepreneurs of the 20th century
he admitted that although he did get
straight a's and did really well in math
he was a lazy kid that almost never
studied his very first take on
entrepreneurship was in college when he
started to sell the one thing he knew
would always be in demand
coke no not the drink actual cocaine in
college mcafee says he began
peddling a product he knew he could sell
cocaine but it's interesting that drug
dealing was really your first foray into
entrepreneurship
yeah well it is it's entrepreneur it's
it's everything it's salesmanship
college was also when he developed his
own drinking habit after college he got
fired from one job for buying weed and
at his next job scheduling trains with
computers he would take lsd in the
morning before work
one day he tried a dose of dmt but
didn't feel anything so
he snorted the entire bag that drinking
and drug habit eventually turned into an
addiction and by 1983 he joined
alcoholics anonymous
then he got a position as a programmer
at lockheed martin
and in 1986 as home computers were
taking off two brothers in pakistan
launched the world's first computer
virus nicknamed brain
and mac if he saw an opportunity he
couldn't pass up
1987 mcafee launches mcafee associates
to create his all-in-one antivirus
software
called virus scan which was the first of
his kind and covered all the dozen or
cell computer viruses that existed back
then
a computer virus is a programmer written
by a hacker with a unique purpose and
that purpose
is to multiply and live the software
worked and he decided to make it free
for anyone to use
within the first month of his launch 4
million people were using it
and by 1990 millions of computers were
using it and companies were paying over
5 million dollars a year to license it
and by 1992 more than half of the
fortune 500 companies had mcafee on
their computers
mcafee became a tech icon not too bad
for a software he created in a day and a
half
mcafee antivirus was created in a day
and a half yes
five years later over half the fortune
500 companies
in the country had begun using it he
became the leading voice on the threat
of computer viruses and by 1992
mcafee associates ipo'd making him worth
80 million
dollars but treble was just around the
corner in 1994 mcafee was pushed out of
management so he sold his shares for 100
million dollars and left the company
and from there he would spend the next
one and a half decades living the life
of a tech mogul with more money than he
knew what to do with
he bought multiple cars built nine homes
became an adrenaline junkie
became a new age yoga guru then built an
adventure sports resort in new mexico
what did you do with the money i wasted
it like everybody has money his next
chapter creating a yoga retreat in
colorado
reinventing himself as a new age guru
bestowing his eternal wisdom on his
guest
the man was born and needed to keep
himself entertained but by 2008
mcafee says he kept getting hit with
frivolous lawsuits by people who wanted
to take his money
and by 2009 he has seemingly hit hard
times and had to auction everything off
he owned
nightline covered this auction on
mcafee's ranch where everything
including his beloved airplanes
winnebagos
exotic art collection even the gold
elephant and dinosaur skull
went on the block years later he would
claim that this was all a ruse to make
it look like he was broke so the
lawsuits would stop
mcafee now claims it was all a charade a
ruse
he was just trying to look broke so
people would stop suing him
mcafee took his remaining millions and
headed to belize in central america
in search of a more simple life little
did he know that this would be the start
of his life as a suspected murderer and
international fugitive
mcafee started life in belize on a
beachfront property but then eventually
moved to the jungles of belize to start
a lab to research plant-grown
antibiotics
he hired a microbiologist to lead the
effort and with it a harem of girls and
ex-felons he hired as bodyguards
or what critics would call his own
private militia that microbiologist
would later claim mcafee committed a
heinous crime against her that mcafee
strongly denies and was never tried for
i'm not going to touch that with a
10-foot pole but even greater trouble
was just around the corner
april 2012 corrupt officials in belize
were trying to extort mcafee for money
and mcafee wouldn't play ball
so they raided his lap under the claim
that he was making drugs in the compound
or at least that's what mcafee claims
back if he claims the government was
harassing him
because he wouldn't pay bribes i was on
the verge of something
when i refused to pay an extortion for
two million dollars and a week later
the gang suppression unit destroyed my
lab
no drugs were found and the american
media ate it up after all an american
millionaire with a history of drugs in
the jungles of belize where girls and
armed ex-felons around him didn't look
so good and made for a great story
i can see both sides of the story and
after that he moved back to his beach
house in belize bringing back the girls
the armed guards and a pack of nine wild
dogs with them which would be the start
of yet another grace with the law
but this time instead of being a
suspected drug lord he becomes a
suspected murderer
[Music]
mcafee's neighbor was a man named greg
fall greg was another american looking
for a peaceful retirement
in the caribbean but it was anything but
peaceful because of mcafee's dogs
they were crazy barked all the time were
aggressive towards anyone walking by and
mcafee had no intention of fixing the
problem
now we're going to be walking past
mcafee's house and there's going to be
dogs there now they're usually fenced up
but he says i just want to warn you so
greg concocted a plan and told his
friends if mcafee wasn't going to take
care of his dogs
he was going to gregor told him that he
was going to poison the dog then not too
long after some poison meat was thrown
into mcafee's backyard
all nine dogs ate it and all nine died
the next night someone snuck into greg
falls home and murdered him at gunpoint
the house showed no sign of forced entry
nothing was taken from inside
the prime suspect of course is mcafee
who of course denies the charges
let me make this perfectly clear i had
nothing to do
with the murder of gregory fall one of
mcafee's beachfront caretakers recounts
in an interview for the showtime
documentary gringo that he was
instructed by mcafee to pay five
thousand dollars to somebody he believed
to be the hitman mcafee hired for the
job
the following morning sometime around
nine o'clock
john called me he said take this money
five thousand dollars
and go put it in this guy's account
cashion says the man who got that money
called him late the night of the murder
to come pick him up
then i realized that this five thousand
dollars was for him
to do that to do what to kill a guy
later on the same man appeared in a
video on mcafee's youtube channel
retracting all the claims he made in
that interview
he claimed that showtime offered him ten
thousand dollars a stupid amount of
money for anyone in belize for a 30
minute interview
and he decided that for that 10k he'll
fabricate whatever lies they wanted to
hear that he was pushed during the
interview that he believes mcafee had
nothing to do with that murder
ten thousand dollars and please it's a
lot of money for 30 minutes
you know who will go against that so i
started to think what i can
improvise what less i can fabricate
to make it credible so i accepted and i
realized that i'm going to improvise and
so whatever i told lanette on that
interview
was a pure fabrication of my imagination
lies and to make it more credible that
is what i did
i believe in my heart that john had
nothing to do with that murder
you can watch the video for yourself on
youtube if you want to for the most part
it looks natural some parts were kind of
scripted but i will let you be the judge
of that
mcafee was never charged with murder but
in 2015 a florida court ordered him to
pay 25 million for being liable for
greg's death
so is mcafee a murderer on one hand
having nine of your dogs poisoned as an
eccentric millionaire were armed guards
that you could easily pay
and being that the murder happened
literally the next day after the dogs
were poisoned
doesn't look good on the other hand the
media dying for a juicy story bribing a
poor laborer that needs money
also sounds plausible and after being
accused of murder mcafee starts his
escape back to america
why did you go on the run because i
think going around i'd be a dead man now
they're trying to arrest me for coming
into the country illegally
mcafee first spent three months in the
jungle before fleeing to guatemala where
he was arrested in 2012.
the whole arrest was caught on camera by
vice he faked a heart attack while he
was being arrested was transported to
the hospital with press following him
and then miraculously opened his eyes to
tell the nurses not to undress him in
front of the cameras
you faked the heart attack sure i faked
it he was then deported back to america
where he met his wife as a prostitute
in miami back in america he started to
build his life back again
becoming a voice for the dangers of
cyber warfare the media liked to call
him the prophet of digital doom and
other names like that during this period
but when you listen to what he had to
say it's pretty reasonable and he makes
some great points
if they did understand it the chinese
would not have been able to steal
21 million records of every person who
has worked for the us government for the
past 50 years the u.s government has
made them
the enemy we need to hire these people
the russians and the chinese are more
practical he also never went back to
paying us income taxes since arriving
back in america
because he believes income taxes aren't
right a noble decision that i commend
but that will come back to haunt him
in 2016 mcafee also decided to run for
president under the libertarian party it
didn't go so well
by 2017 mcafee started becoming a huge
advocate for cryptocurrencies as a way
to prevent governments from collecting
income taxes
when privacy coins are widely used
governments will
no longer be able to collect income
taxes
where one of the things he would do was
to share coin of the day tweets where he
would talk about all coins that he
believed have value
mcafee announces he's running for
president again in the 2020 ballot and
because of this advocacy against taxes
against big government promoting crypto
by 2018 mcafee field things were
starting to really heat up
after all he was openly not paying taxes
openly committing a crime
making him an easy target i have not
paid taxes for eight years i've made no
secret of it i have not filed returns
and by january 22nd he flees the u.s
while at the same time the irs was
convening a grand jury in tennessee to
charge him his wife and four of his
campaign workers with irs related
felonies
mcafee post this video while on the run
today january 22nd
the irs has convened a grand jury in the
state
of tennessee to charge myself my wife
mrs mcafee
four of my campaign workers with
unspecified
irs crimes
of a felonious nature today crypto
community
we are at war which brings us back to
where we were at the beginning of this
video and everything leading up to his
arrest on october 3rd 2020 in spain
that same month that court in tennessee
charged him for tax evasion demanding
that he'd be extradited back to the us
to face trial
and after six gruelling months in prison
mcafee was slapped with a federal
indictment on crypto fraud charges in
march 2021
he was charged with tax evasion failure
to file taxes and securities fraud for
those alcorn shadows on twitter making
it one of the first big criminal cases
to involve crypto
federal prosecutors accused him of
scamming his large twitter following
with all coins as an age-old pump and
dump scheme
mcafee says the us government wanted to
make an example out of me
for encouraging people not to pay income
taxes and so forth which i 100
agree with because let's face it elon
musk has moved to crypto and stock
markets way more than mcafee ever has
yet he hasn't faced any pump and dump
charges this just goes to show how
subjective loss and prosecuting can be
which leads us to his taking of his own
i will spend life rest of my life in
prison
because the united states
wants to use me as
an example
so did he off himself well it's
important to note that we are now
entering speculation land with very
limited facts about what actually
happened
but here are both sides of the argument
[Music]
listen the guy was 75 on the run for a
good chunk of his life just got word
that he was about to be extradited back
to the us for a case that was already
set against him his health was already
taking a toll and he would most likely
die in prison
so if you were in his shoes you could
see how this would make a man weigh his
options
and let's face it the us does have a
history of assassinating people way more
powerful than mcafee but on the other
hand
was the stuff he was saying and doing
that bad enough to justify a hit
as to the theatrics and the rack tattoo
and the threats of releasing
incriminating data
well it could have been a bluff to get
his enemies off his back and as you can
tell he's a man that loves attention
so might as well go out with a bang with
some mystery
on the other hand his wife came out and
said that he showed no signs of wanting
to off himself
that the extradition order was not a
surprise to them and they already have
plans laid out
john mcafee was not super i spoke with
him a few hours
before he was found dead we spoke about
the court's decision to extradite him
to the u.s it did not come as a surprise
to either of us
we were prepared for that decision and
had a plan of action already in place to
appeal that decision
i blame the us authorities for this
tragedy
because of these politically motivated
charges against him my husband is now
dead
his lawyer said the same thing and if
anyone would be able to gather
incriminating evidence against people in
power
it would be a millionaire cyber security
expert on the run so did he off himself
i'm gonna lean on the side of i don't
know probably not the answer you wanted
to hear
but until we get more evidence let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below
i personally don't think this is as
clear-cut of a case as the other
very prominent case of a powerful man
that had an island who off himself whose
first name starts with a j and last name
starts with an e
but i think the life of john mcafee can
be summed up in this one tweet he made
while in prison
my life's conflict stem from one source
my best friend
and my worst enemy were both myself
so what do you think really happened
with john mcafee let me know in the
comments below
try to keep a civil down there and of
course magic spoon you guys know what to
do link below magicspoon.com with the
coupon code jtran
for five dollars off your order now in
the us and canada if you enjoy videos
like this we make them every single week
for free on the most provocative stuff
in the world of business geopolitics
power all of the above all you have to
do is click that subscribe button below
if you want more behind
behind-the-scenes stuff data life kind
of stuff you can follow me on instagram
at jtrend.io it will be linked below or
you can just go to jaketrend.org
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you